hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on foreigner again and
today is Thursday so we have that dead
stream recap we're gonna go a little bit
of into some info that being about title
update 1.22 which we talked about last
week of course as well some other things
like new content of the week as always
like the video if you do enjoy subscribe
if you're new I cover the leaks the info
the news the informational side of
foreigner I like to cover with that
let's get started as I stated previously
patch 1.2 2 is also out as well as the
training trials training arena
everything we talked about in
yesterday's video if you want you can
cliff the I on the top right it also be
at the end of the video if you do want
to check that out in that video we
discussed like I said the training
trials what's going to be in it the
rewards it looks like what the arena
mode looks like as well as the
adjustments and patches of all the new
of the old characters that being bug
fixes adjustments other good stuff like
that so like I said check that out if
you haven't already the event playlist
dance of death is also coming back if
you're unaware dents of death is similar
to 2v2 brawl but the only way to kill
them is that both players on one team
have to be dead at the same time each
time you kill someone adds an extra
second to the respawn so I believe the
original minimum timer is 2 seconds then
once you die again you have 3 seconds so
it gets a lot harder every time you die
that's going to be in the event the
event section right by where your
faction leader should be and but sadly
the new arena maps will not be available
for this event unfortunately that's kind
of a bummer I really wish that they
added that in there is new content of
the week and it's going to be one free
roam emo for 7000 steel called ready to
rumble your guy kind of gets in this
boxer stance it's kind of cool but I
don't really know if it's worth 7000
steel that's entirely up to you though
if you want to grab that and then other
bits of info is that there was a recent
Centurion clip that popped up on reddit
and it was also on youtube I believe
splice put it up on YouTube and have I
put it up on reddit on other for honor
youtubers they put up this infinite
combo chain of Centurion where he would
hit you in the head
obviously knocking you on your ass then
doing the new light heavy combo putting
you in this infinite combo where you
couldn't get out of it according to the
devs it can be parried with strict
timing the des will be changing it in a
live update next week so that's the
light chain into heavy is delayed by 100
milliseconds on a Miss any charge job
recovery on a hit is increased by
another 100 milliseconds hopefully that
will cause players to hopefully not be
in that infinite
anymore I personally have not dealt with
this thing as I haven't even put an
update yet but hopefully that doesn't
occur and then also at the end of season
five of all the duel tournament Season
three four and five rewards are going to
be replaced with season six tournament
rewards so if you want to get some type
of ornament or whatever it happens to be
for your character that is a season
three four or five tournament reward
definitely hop on and grab it I
personally have already got the things I
needed so I'm just waiting for season
six to come along get some duel
tournament wins and then go get my new
ornament and then lastly I want to go
over this thing that I saw yesterday but
didn't have enough time to make the
video since this came up after the video
was made yesterday but basically in the
reddit post that described the whole
patch notes for a title update 1.22 like
I said I talked about yesterday there
was a there was apparently a mix-up and
according to Eric Pope he sticky this
comment to the top of the reddit post
and it said you may have noticed some
executions mentions in the notes that
don't exist yes that's a mistake sorry
also don't expect these to arrive
tomorrow they will come soon and then
somebody asked what soon means because
they always say that all the time and
they said reasonably soon so that
believes me to believe that we're
hopefully going to beginning new
executions and judging by the way that
it looks it probably fits more along the
fact that we're going to be getting at
the release of season six or a little
bit after season six seeing as the fifth
campaign is almost over then we're gonna
go into a little bit of a cool-down
stage on the off season for a couple
weeks then head into season six get all
those new rework so whatever happens to
be and maybe even get new executions I
don't know about you guys but I've been
waiting a very long [ __ ] time for
some new execution some new fresh
content like that that's worth it so
that would be really nice to see what
they're gonna do but now to end the
video since there really wasn't much to
talk about there was a lot of info
discussed yesterday but obviously not
today dan do you guys off I want to ask
you guys the question what do you guys
think of arena mode the arena mode the
training trial is that being apprenticed
in warrior trials the training media tab
all that stuff I'm assuming it's been
out long enough for people to have
played it and if you haven't played it
from the stuff that you've possibly seen
from early access of youtubers or just
anything that I've talked about in my
video from yesterday what do you guys
think about it do you guys think it's a
good thing for the new players good for
veteran player
I want to hear all your opinions on it
whether you like it dislike it or
anything any other type of opinion you
have on it I'd really love to know in
the comments below but as I stated
before it's gonna be the end of the
video today guys thank you guys for
checking out the video like the if you
did enjoy everyone has helped me out
subscribe if you're new like I said in
the beginning in the video I covered the
patches the patch notes the leaks the
description all that all the information
on site or on our patch notes leaks new
heroes new updates new events all that
good stuff
I cover on this channel so definitely
stick around if you want to be
up-to-date with everything out for honor
my two most recent videos are gonna be
on screen if you guys do want to check
that out I mean that guy's hope if ago
yesterday and peace out